[موسيقى]
يا رائع ،
هذا ما
[موسيقى
] الضجيج يهاجم الأذنين فقط
حياة مثيرة رائعة
[موسيقى]
هناك دفء وروح هنا التي
تشعر بها حقًا بمجرد أن
تخرج في الفم
تكون حواسي مبتهجة  أقوياء ،
إنهم لذيذون ، يمكنك فقط أن تأكل
وأكل وأكل هذه ،
أنا لست فقط في الشرق الأوسط أنا في
رجل آه قلب هذه المنطقة حيث
يبدو أن كل شيء بدأ ، انظر إلى ذلك
للوصول إلى رجل في الأردن
هو أن أخضع نفسي على الفور إلى
نشاز الأصوات والروائح والأذواق اللذيذة ،
لكن للوصول إلى عمان يعني أيضًا الوصول
إلى مفترق طرق العالم ،
رجل غني ، رجل فقير ، رجل متسول لص ،
كلهم هنا في هذا النسيج الغني لل
ياة ويجلسون فوقهم جميعًا  الهاشميون
العائلة المالكة الأردنية التي حكمت
على مدى المائة عام الماضية ،
هذه هي مدينة فيلادلفيا القديمة
التي أطلق عليها الرومان اسم
فيلادلفيا هي حبك الأخوي ، أنا
واحدة من أقدم المدن في العالم
الأمير علي بن هو  الحسين هو ابن
الملك الراحل الحسين ،
لذا فهو الأخ غير الشقيق لملك اليوم
الملك عبد الله الثاني ،
حسنًا ، كم مرة يحدث هذا لك ،
وآمل ألا يحدث هذا كثيرًا في الواقع إلى
أين تأخذني الآن جيدًا ، فنحن
ننتقل إلى أحد أقدم  أه
مطعم فلافل
يأكل الفلافل قد يكون مبتذلاً ولكن
مع الأمير يغفر ذلك حسنًا ،
سنحصل على ست قطع ست قطع
، هل
أنت صورة تسوي الفاتورة
[موسيقى]
العائلة المالكة في الأردن على عكس ربما
الملكيات الأخرى والحكام على
ما
يرام
عمداً  تجربة شيقة
مع الفلافل مع الملك في
منتصف الشارع والجميع يريد صورة سيلفي
معه
وبنعمة
وسحر مدهشين يسمح لكل ذلك أن يحدث
الآن نحن ذاهبون إلى لجنة الفيلم الملكية
الأمير علي هو رئيس مجلس الإدارة  من
مجلس الإدارة زوجته الأميرة آريم
مفوضة ، كم هو جميل أن أراك من الجميل
أن أراك
بالطبع لقد عرفت الأميرة ريم منذ أيامها
عندما كانت إمبراهيمي زميلة في
CNN Brahimi تنضم إلى m  الآن من الخلف ،
انتقلت من أخبار التلفزيون إلى الملوك ،
ما زلت أقوم بعمل الأخبار
التلفزيونية لماذا كان هذا هو شكل الفن الذي
أعتقد أنه ربما شعرت بالحاجة إلى
الإحياء هناك بحاجة إلى مساحة
للشباب الذين يحبون السينما
الذين يريدون هذا المكان حيث يمكنهم مشاهدة
الأفلام حتى يتمكنوا من التحدث عن فيلم ،
يربط بيت أفلام الرجل الكلاسيكي
بالثقافة والمعاصرة ، هذا حرفيًا
في وسط عمان أن القلعة
هي أقدم جزء من المدينة منذ العصور
القديمة ويظهر  كل الحضارات أه المختلفة
التي جاءت من خلال يا إلهي ،
هذا أمر غير عادي في الواقع لا
تنخدع بالنوع أه الظاهر من
المظهر التقليدي الذي تراه
لأن هناك نوعًا من
الحديث والتقليدي جنبًا إلى جنب
ما ترى أنه دورك
دور العائلة دور العائلة المالكة
هنا العائلة نفسها وجلالته
مظلة لكل الأشخاص الفسيفسائيين المختلفين
في البلاد
في نفس الوقت هي فكرة أن
لديك الحرية التي يمكنك  احتفل
بثقافتك أه أنك تحظى بالاحترام
بغض النظر عن خلفيتك ،
فإن مشاكل الأردن ليست على الأقل
الثلاثة ملايين لاجئ الذي يستضيفه الآن
البلد ليس لديه نفط
ولا ثروة كبيرة وهناك دائمًا
توترات محتدمة في مكان ما
يكون فيه أفراد العائلة المالكة مثل الأشخاص
الجادين ولكن
الودودون  أتجرأ على قول
إنسان هنا لأنه مجتمع قبلي
يرون جلالته على أنه رأس
القبيلة ولهذا السبب أحبه هنا
[موسيقى]
هذه نظرة رائعة على الضوء الفاتح
إلى الجمال المذهل
لرؤية الرجل في الذهبي  ساعة هي
رؤية المدينة بكل مجدها
عندما تصبح حتى الفظيعة
[موسيقى]
قلعة رجل بناها الرومان ،
إنها تذكير دراماتيكي بأنه على مدى
آلاف السنين تم احتلال هذه
الأرض أو إدارتها من قبل كل إمبراطورية
أو ديكتاتور تقريبًا  وكل واحد ترك بصماته
كان عندك
الآشوريون والموآبيون والفرس والرومان واليونانيون
والبابليون والبيزنطيون.  حدس
والحملات الصليبية التي أدت إلى
الإمبراطورية العثمانية والانتداب البريطاني
أخيرًا وصلت إلى اليوم
والمملكة الأردنية الهاشمية
، لم يكن هذا الجزء من العالم
بلا احتلال أبدًا طالما يعرف التاريخ
متى تكون الحياة صعبة ،
ينتقل الناس إلى
كوميديا ساتيرام  لتحمل ذلك ،
نبيل
هو ملك التهكم الذي حكم
الأردن لعقود من الزمن ،
كما تعلمون ، لقد بدأت مع هذا البلد ، فأنا
أصغر بعشرين عامًا فقط من البلد
الذي يسخر من الملك رئيس
الوزراء القوي
ولكن لا يوجد شيء عسكري حوله.  قال
روحه الدعابة
مثل أوسكار وايلد إنه يمكنك إخبار
الناس بأي شيء
طالما أنك تفعل ذلك بروح الدعابة إذا
لم تفعل ذلك بروح الدعابة فإنهم يقتلونك
ولكن هل تشكك في السلطة هنا
ومن الصواب أن تحكم
لا ، هذا ليس وظيفتي  هو حقًا
إظهار عيوب
حاكم شعب رئيس
وزراء الحكومة ولكن في
روح الدعابة
أنت سيدي
هل أنت ممثل أنا
ممثل
لا
أنا nevillios marcos philadelphios أنا
g  حاكم هذه المنطقة فكر في نبيل
بهذه الطريقة الأصدقاء الأردنيون ضحكوني
كيف تسافر
حصانًا أو عربة ، أسافر مع أي من
سيدي
أنا
أطير ،
إنه واحد من
هؤلاء الرجال هو مقر شركة الطاقة
الأردنية التي عرضت لي أن تريني القاع
البلد في الواقع هو الجزء السفلي من
العالم حيث سنأخذ المياه
لاستعادة حيويتنا وحيويتنا
[الموسيقى]
انظر إلى
هاتين الفرطتين القديمتين اللتين تسيران إلى البحر ،
إنها ليست مجرد بحر
، البحر الميت
نحن في أدنى نقطة
في الكوكب
في المرة الأخيرة التي كنت فيها هنا ، كان مستوى المياه
أعلى بكثير ،
يجب أن أقول إنني مصدوم
من الطريقة التي انحسر فيها ، نعم إنه
لأمر محزن للغاية أن
التبخر والتآكل يعني أن مستويات سطح البحر
تنخفض على الأقل  مترًا في السنة ،
ولكن في الوقت الحالي ، هناك الكثير من الماء
لرجلين مسنين
غاضبين للاستحمام ، وقت مناسب
للتخلي [ضحك]
في أي مكان في العالم يمكنك فقط الجلوس
على الماء والشعور بالاسترخاء
والسعادة ، أحاول
الوقوف  لا أستطيع حتى
إلقاء نظرة على  هذا الخبير يعبر
ساقيه ،
إن الطفو الفائق لدينا هو أحد الآثار الجانبية
لملح البحر الميت الذي يكون أكثر ملوحة بحوالي 10
مرات إذا كنت تريد أن
تبدو مياه البحر العادية بلا أيد أم
[موسيقى]
فهي تحبك الماء هنا حيث
تعانق قاع البحيرة  لكنك تحصل على
الوحل وهذا هو الذي
أتدلك به وأختنق
هذا تدليك حقيقي
لم أحصل عليه أبدًا بنفسي
التمسك بي كما تعلم أنني ألتزم بك
بالتأكيد
مثل مقشر ، أليس كذلك
لقد قلت الكلمة الصحيحة ، لقد أزلت
كل القمامة من بشرتك ، حسنًا ، ما
عليك فعله هو الاستمرار في التنفس
والتخلص من التوتر ، نعم والأكسجين هنا
بقدر ما تستطيع بالمناسبة ، حسنًا ،
ستتنفس تحصل على أكسجين أكثر بنسبة 15 في المائة
15  هل هناك المزيد من الأوكسجين والحرية ،
حسنًا ، والحكومة الأردنية
لا تفرض عليك رسومًا مقابل هذا الأردن ،
هذه روح الأردن ، إنها تلطخك
، ثم تترك بشرتك ناعمة ،
كيف هذا يعجبك أنها
بلد كبير القلب؟  يأخذ
كل شخص لدينا  36
دولة أه من جنسيات
اللاجئين ولكن بالطبع الأردنيون والفلسطينيون بشكل أساسي
، لذا إذا
جمعت هؤلاء معًا ، فستخلق دينامو
من الثقافات المختلفة
التي ربطوا معًا
البحر الميت ونوبل لديهما الكثير من
القواسم المشتركة ، كلاهما صعب  لا هوادة فيها
وتحول الشدائد إلى
صديق ومثل الأردن يستمر في التعويم ، يأتي
ما قد
تراه
أين يمكنك تجربة شيء
جميل مثل
أنه حقًا
عالم يسوده السلام
[موسيقى]
آه
إذا ذهب المرء إلى الأردن ولم يزور
البتراء ، فربما  بالإضافة إلى أنني بقيت في
المنزل ،
لقد كنت هنا من قبل
ودائمًا ما كانت مليئة
بالناس والحمير والضوضاء والروائح ،
هذا علاج رائع ، هناك
طريقة واحدة وطريقة واحدة للخروج من المدينة القديمة
وهي من خلال المرضى والمرضى.  جرب
كل ما هو خاص به ،
تذكر كل هؤلاء الملوك والإمبراطوريات الذين
أداروا هذا المكان
هنا ، كان النبطيون
قبل 2000 عام هم الذين أنشأوا عاصمة إمبراطورية من
الصخور ، وكان السيخ في الواقع نتاجًا لـ
حدث طبيعي ، حدث زلزال
منذ ملايين السنين أدى إلى تفكيك الصخور ،
وإذا نظرت إلى التكوين ، فستدرك
أنه إذا كان سيتم دفعه معًا ، فسيكون
مناسبًا تمامًا مرة
أخرى ، وكان النبطيون تجارًا بارعين
وعلماء هيدرولوجيين لامعين
كانوا يعرفون أنهم بحاجة إلى الماء إذا كان هذا
كان المكان ينجح حقًا إذا كان
عليهم البقاء على قيد الحياة ،
لذا فقد تكيفوا ونحتوا وخلقوا
قنوات مائية في هذه الصخرة ،
يمكنك الحصول على تلميح عنها
، ثم ترى المزيد
يا إلهي في كل مرة
يكون الأمر
مذهلاً وهناك
إنها خزينة البتراء
انظر ،
خذها في
التنفس
[موسيقى]
كان النبطيون
تجارًا ومعلمو قوة في مجال الأعمال
، وكما يمكنك أن تتخيل عندما
تصل إلى هنا اليوم ،
فإن خلفاءهم
ينتظرونك بالفعل
[موسيقى]
موقع موقع رائع ، هذا هو
ما يعنيه
أن تكون رائعًا  مثير للإعجاب وقد
صرحوا بذلك بقولهم أن هذا هو من
نحن ،
هذا هو مكتب الأستاذ سامي
حيث نشأ ومهمته
الآن تتأكد من  أتفهم تمامًا
الأهمية
العميقة لموقع التراث العالمي لليونسكو
كل يوم ، فأنا أراه بشكل مختلف
كل يوم
لأنه
بالنسبة لي يبدو أنه التركيز على
صورة كلما زاد تركيزك كلما
رأيت أكثر كلما اكتشفت أن
البتراء مثيرة للإعجاب.  بالتأكيد
ولكن يا سيدي المرشدين الأفضل الموجودين في
كل مكان ،
أدركت أخيرًا أن ما
جذب انتباهي
هو عيونهم والخط الأسود من
حولهم ،
ما الذي تضعه على عينيك ،
لماذا مجرد تنظيف العيون يكسر العيون
من الرمال ، والشمس المختلفة
حقًا نعم بالطبع  لذا فهي ليست
مستحضرات تجميل
من
الشمس ،
نعم
أجلس هنا
،
هل تنفجر ، لا لا لا لا لا ،
أعني أنه يمكنني مسحها من
[ضحك]
ما يمكن أن يكون خاطئًا
للملابس
بترا بالطبع هو أكثر من
تصعد الخزانة إلى أعلى الطريق وينتهي بك الأمر في
وسط المدينة ،
وكان هذا هو القلب النابض للبتراء ،
لذا كم عدد الأشخاص الذين كانوا هنا
حوالي 40 ألف شخص خلال
أبرز أحداث البتراء بين القرن الأول
قبل الميلاد  في القرن الأول الميلادي ،
كانت مدينة مزدحمة للغاية
لأنهم انخرطوا في التجارة مع
التجارة
، وكانوا الأغنى في العالم كله
في ذلك الوقت بسبب طرق التجارة
التي أصبحوا تجارًا
يقدمونها ،
وحصلوا على الرسوم
والضرائب  الأغنياء والنبلاء
أعلى الخنزير وكل شخص آخر في الأسفل
مكان جميل مع منظر
يمكنك إلقاء نظرة على ريفراف
لأكثر من ألف عام ، تم
التخلي عن البتراء ثم بدأ الأوروبيون في
الحفر كما أرادوا في عام
1812 وذلك الاستكشاف  تحت العديد من القبعات
يستمر اليوم
الأستاذ الحسن يقول إن ما نراه
هو جزء بسيط مما يتبقى
لتكتشفه ، أغمض عينيك ، نعم ولا تفتحها ،
سآخذك بأمان
إلى الحافة لا تقلق يمكنك فتح
عينيك  الآن
يا نجاح باهر المفاجأة
أن المدرج
يتكيف مع أربعة آلاف من الجمهور ،
وعندما أتيت إلى خراب قديم مثل
هذا ،
كنت أتوق دائمًا إلى العودة في
الوقت المناسب للحظة فقط
لأرى ما  كانت في الواقع مثل
الضجيج ، والروائح والأوساخ ، أوه
فقط
للحظة صغيرة ،
أعدني إلى هناك ،
هذه الصخور محفورة بأدلة على حضارات
البتراء القديمة وما تمثله محفورًا
في الحمض النووي للأردن اليوم
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
]  هي صحراء بالتأكيد
ولكن في الفيلم كانت
حرب النجوم المريخ ومنزل علاء الدين ،
إنها صحراء واديرام الأردن
حيث حدثت إحدى أعظم لحظات التاريخ في
عام 1916 ، انضم ضابط بريطاني إلى
تحالف من المتمردين العرب الذين
سيثورون ضد الإمبراطورية العثمانية.
الولادة المبكرة للمملكة الهاشمية
وأصبح ذلك الضابط البريطاني معروفًا باسم
لورنس المصفوفة
[موسيقى] تم
تخليده في الفيلم في عام 1962
[موسيقى]
تم إعادة إنشاء هذا الهجوم العربي الشهير بعناية
هذه الأيام من قبل
شركة إحياء التراث الأردني التي
يديرونها أسبوعيًا للسائحين.
لقد تعاملت مع كل شيء
بنفسي ،
فنحن لسنا بعيدين عن المحطة
عندما بدأ الهجوم وبدأ الهجوم ونعود
إلى عام 1916.
إنهم متمردين
لقد تم بذل الكثير من العمل الشاق للوصول إلى
هذا الأمر بشكل صحيح
تاريخيًا ، فنحن نعلم كيف تنتهي هذه القصة
من فوز الثوار العرب
بالحراس وأنا في هذا الصدد يتم أسرني جيدًا
إذا كان هذا ما حدث ، فمن الأفضل أن أنزل
من القطار بطريقة أو بأخرى
[  الموسيقى]
عندما أخذني كرهينة ذهب من أجلها
بحماسة ،
أعني أنني حاولت أن أبتسم كما لو كان كل شيء
ممتعًا ، أليس كذلك
ولم يفعل
[موسيقى]
إنه إنتاج يستحق الشاشة
الكبيرة وليس هذا مفاجئًا
ظهر القطار في العديد من الأفلام التي
يتذكرها صاحب السمو الملكي الأمير علي
من قبل
، وقد انضم إلي الآن في وادي رم ،
وهو يريد أن يمنحني جولة في الجزء الخلفي
من فيلم هوليوود الذي يتم إنتاجه في
الأردن ،
ولا يمكننا تحديد الفيلم الذي
سبب ذلك.  إنه مهم للأردن جيدًا
بمعنى أننا نقوم
بتطوير صناعة الأفلام الخاصة بنا
ولكنه أيضًا يجلب فوائد حقيقية
للناس إنه يتعلق بالأشخاص الذين يعملون
على الأرض وتستفيد المجتمعات المحلية جميعًا
من هذه الصناعة الرائعة
هذا هو العالم الحديث الذي
يريد الناس رؤيته أنهم يريدون أن
يتخيلوا أنهم يريدون فهم
ما يحدث ،
هذا هو المكان المناسب لي لإنهاء
وقتي في الأردن ،
كم مرة تأتي إلى هنا
بشكل جيد ، لقد أتيت إلى هنا في كثير من الأحيان  بقدر ما أستطيع
أن الصحراء مكان جميل إنه
نظيف إنه نقي
إنه مكان يمكنك فيه تجديد نشاطك
في هذا العالم هذا العالم المجنون الذي نعيش
فيه حيث كل شيء ،
فكيف تقول إنه
سريع الخطى من الجيد العودة إلى
أصول
ما يحدث
داخل
الأمير علي
عندما يأتي إلى هنا وينظر إلى
ما يحدث داخل حليف الأمير
لدينا كلمة باللغة
العربية وتسمى السكينة
تعني السلام
والسلام في القلب قطعة من
السلام في
روحك وهذا ما تشعر به
"  إعادة النظر إلى عالم
لانهائي وعالم لانهائي مكان لانهائي
وهذا كل ما نشعر به
[موسيقى
] قد يفشل في
الإعجاب وأعتقد أن الأمير علي قد أعطاني
الكلمة التي تصف كل هذا على أفضل وجه ،
إنها subkina
peac  ه من الروح الهدوء الذي
نسعى إليه جميعًا
وستريد أن تجد الجزء الخاص بك
من sekina عند زيارتك لأنه بدون
شك رجل وأردن جزء من
عالم العجائب
[الموسيقى]
أنت